trevor williams has just been okay
uh one in five five fifty and seven
starts certainly not what he wants
there is the slider to strike him out to
retire the reds in order
looking for bounce back and the reds
need bounce back out of anthony
diesclefani now that's two fastballs
back to back that were strikes we didn't
see that in the entirety of the ball
game in cincinnati the whole game
oh stockist down on strikes two
strikeouts now
for williams five in a row sent down
that was a nice one there yeah takes
care of garcia
an error and two left for the reds
swinging a miss nasty breaking ball from
diesel
fighting in his second strikeout tucker
barnhart 179 to homer's eight rbis
barn harp center field hit
well out of here red strike first
number three for tucker alford appears
to be shaking up it is
as he came into the wall there tears up
the wall cap flipped up so you could
just tell that he wasn't quite
ready for that wall being there again a
new ballpark for him
ryan hausen the head athletic i think he
was going to try and put his foot on the
wall and go up
you know kind of try to climb the wall
and it looked like he made contact
before he was really ready
he's slowly walking off hopefully he's
okay because
it looks like he's coming out of the
game yeah i think he's fine
bottom rips it down the right field line
this will be extra basis
and into second base with double number
five here in 2020.
now trevor williams has to deal with a
eu genio suarez
the 1-1 ripped suarez
bye-bye baby he didn't miss that one
a missile to left a three-run job off of
williams and the reds are in business
here in the third
four or nothing cincinnati he was
stranded aziz kofani stranded one in the
first
two in the second charging his suarez
barehand play not in time
here's frazier there's another hit
maybe here we go i'll be able to take
third on this let's see yeah he turns
the bag
and frazier read that so well he got
into second base he just stayed right
with it
he saw that castianos was thinking of
throwing to third
turns that single into two men in
scoring position
polanco a strikeout victim swinging back
in the second
and the first pitch here center field
good one
given chase and reaches up and makes a
catch this will play to run
and the runner from second base moving
up pirates on the board but an
outstanding play by goodwin
he doesn't catch that ball and the bases
are clear
bell off mustaches to suarez
stretch out wow pinball
man but the reds somehow
come out with an out
so stallings trying to start something
here in the fourth with two men out
stallings out to left and that gets out
of here for a home run jacob stallings
with his second of the year and the
pirates play long ball
it's four to two you can tell by the
sound
i mean you knew for sure it was hit very
well
and foul tip and a broken bat williams
has sent down six in a row since the
pick off
the reds suarez belted a three run
home run in the third inning flew out to
right
suarez opposite field and
out of here second home run of the game
for
suarez his third in the last
two games how about you suarez
and now uh bustakas can't hold his swing
the strikeout number five
for williams brings up brian goodwin
season high for pitches look at that
back-to-back strikeouts for trevor
he's fanned six reds tonight the lefty
frazier on deck
oh that gets away but it was ball four
no further damage big moment in this
game bases full of pirates
two outs amir garrett called upon to
face the lefty
adam frazier in this one here it comes
breaking ball and a nasty pitch from
garrett
up to the challenge amir and now the man
of the hour
eugenio suarez
did he get another one suarez number
three of the night
how about you suarez mercy
three home runs and three consecutive
trips to the play
second air in the inning for the reds
and another ground ball
farmer garcia this time they turn it
over and that's the ball game
6-2 reds as they take game three of this
four-game
set they've won two of the first three
and will go after a series victory
tomorrow afternoon
what a night for a eugenio suarez